(audience applauding)
- Okay, so it's great to see you.
It's y'all's first time here.
- Yeah.
- It's like your fourth time, I think.
- Fourth or fifth time.
- [Kelly] You love me, Nick.
(audience laughs)
- I love you.
- [Kelly] But welcome to Kevin
and Joe for coming to the show.
- [Kevin] Thank you.
Thank you for having us.
- And thank you for bringing this.
(audience applauding)
- Oh, yeah.
- I have to ask, before we start on this,
I saw that, I'm obsessed
with "Bridgerton."
- Ooh.
- Coz I have eyes and ears.
(both laughing)
And I saw that you posted
this, so I wanna show this,
and then you stomp and then.
(Kelly gasps)
♪ Hey ♪
(audience laughing)
- [Joe] It's very fitting.
- [Kelly] ♪ Oh my God ♪
- [Joe] It's all about the hair.
- So you look like the viscount.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
I get a lot of tweets saying
that we look like some
of the Bridgerton brothers.
Bridgerton guys so.
- That's amazing.
- I decided it was time
that I put on the gear.
I was gonna wear it today,
but I just felt like
I don't have a reason.
Maybe too much?
- Oh my God, that would've been
awesome for me specifically.
- Next time.
Next time.
- Yes. Wait y'all should dress up
as that for like Halloween.
I'm just saying I'm just saying.
- [Joe] Halloween show maybe?
- [Kelly] I'm just, yeah. I'm
just saying it would be really
yes let's do it.